Today we're going to continue our discussion of conditions proceeded.
In particular,
we look at the waiver of an express condition proceeded in Clark versus West in
1908 New York case in this case,
the plaintiff William Clark agreed to write a case book about corporations law
for the defendant West a publisher.
The ingredient included a clause requiring Clark to abstain from having any
liquor during the time of the contract and said quote that the payment to him in
accordance with the terms of this contract of any money in excess of $2 per page
is dependent on the faithful performance of this unquote Clark was to be paid $6
per page if he abstained.
Clark drank and west paid him $2 per page for the completed work.
Clark sued seeking the additional $4 per page and also claim that the copyright
of the book in the name of a corporation violated the terms of the agreement.
The trial court overruled the defendant's dimmer.
The appellate court sustained the dimmer and the instinct court reversed
overruling the Demora and remanded.
The issue in this case is,
was the promise not to drink a condition proceeded waived by the defendant.
Now,
as an aside,
uh,
the contract law used to distinguish between conditions proceeded and condition
subsequent.
And Luckily these days you don't have to really know about this distinction.
But,
uh,
the distinction used to me made that a condition proceedings,
was a condition that the duty to perform did not exist until that condition was
fulfilled.
Whereas with a condition subsequent,
there was,
uh,
an initial duty to perform that might be eliminated if subsequently a certain
condition came about.
The real difference between a condition preceding then a condition subsequent is
whether it was the promises or the promise sores,
duty to establish,
uh,
whether the condition came about or not.
But let's go to a quiz.
So the defendant argued that the plane is promise and not to drink was
consideration for the payment of the difference between the $2 and the $6 per
page.
The plaintiff argued that the plaintiffs abstinence from alcohol was the
condition proceeding.
Why is this distinction important to the analysis of the case?
Well if the plaintiffs promise not to drink was consideration in exchange for an
additional $4 per page than the promise could not be modified except by a new
agreement between the two parties supported by a separate consideration.
However,
if the abstention from drinking was merely a condition that did not go to the
consideration of the contract,
it could be waived by the defendant without any additional consideration.
The court held that the promise not to drink was merely a condition proceeded in
the words of the court.
It was quote not a contract to write books in order that the plaintiff shall
keep sober but a contract containing a stipulation that he shall keep sober so
that he may write satisfactory books.
The court compared the clause requiring Clark to abstain to the clauses
governing other terms of the agreement such as those relating to time and method
of delivery of the manuscript,
revision approved citation of cases,
assignment of copyrights,
keeping track of new cases and citations for new additions and other details
which might be waived by the defendant if he saw fit to do so.
To be clear.
Some conditions do go to the consideration of an agreement.
A home buyer could have waved without additional consideration.
The promise,
a promise to pay that is conditioned on the contractor using coho pipe,
but the home buyer could not waive with out additional consideration.
The promise to pay that is conditioned on the contractor building the entire
house.
It's one thing to say for our contractor to go to the buyer and say,
Hey,
I don't have any coho pipe.
Is it alright if I substitute Redding pipe?
That can be that kind of a condition to pay can be waived,
but for a contractor to go to a buyer and say,
hey,
I'm not feeling like building your house.
The buyer can't agree to waive the condition of the entire house being built.
That kind of a duty of the buyer to pay conditioned on the house.
That goes too much to the entire consideration.
In this case,
the plaintiff's complaint alleged that West New Clark failed to observe the
stipulation.
The opinion says long before the plaintiff had completed the manuscript of the
first book undertaken under the contract,
the defendant had full knowledge of the plaintiffs non observance of that
stipulation and that was such knowledge.
He not only accepted the completed manuscript without a objection,
but is this bad behavior on the part of West really objectionable?
In essence,
the court is saying to west,
how dare you not tell Clark what Clark already knew that Clark was drinking,
but why does Clark have an obligation?
But why does west to have an obligation to tell Clark that West knows that Clark
is drinking Clark?
It didn't promise not to drink and West didn't promise to tell Clark if West
learns that Clark is drinking.
The most important allegation is that West not only accepted the completed
manuscript for the book,
but also quote repeatedly avowed and represented to the plaintiff that he was
entitled to and would receive said royalty payments.
That is the additional $4 per page and plaintiff believed in relied upon such
representations unquote.
These actions according to the court,
if established would prove defendant's waiver of plaintiff's performance of that
contract.
Stipulation.
Therefore,
the court reversed the dimmer and remanded the case as we discussed in the
previous lecture and express condition allows a promissory to avoid performance
unless a certain event occurs the existence of a condition in a contract and
makes what would have been an unconditional promise into a conditional promise.
If the event does not occur,
there is not a duty to perform and the contract is discharged.
Some conditions like the one at issue here or for the conditional promissory its
benefit.
If Clark fails to stay sober west the conditional promise or is able to withhold
part of the promised payment,
but if the condition is not deemed to be consideration for the promises,
promise the promise or can waive it without any additional consideration.
Waiver of a condition is in effect a contract modification because it increases
the promises duty to perform before beyond the original contract terms.
The original contract term was for a conditional promise.
The waiver makes it an unconditional promise.
The contract modification would normally need to be supported by additional
consideration to be enforceable.
But courts courts make an exception when the condition precedent was quote,
not the consideration for the contract unquote.
This exception was evident in Clark versus West.
The court emphasized that the stipulation prohibiting Clark from drinking again
was not a contract to write books in order that the plaintiff shall keep sober,
but a contract that he keeps sober so that he may write satisfactory book.
The court's language here can be criticized.
Wordplay aside West might have reasonably wanted plaintiff to be sober as a
proxy for the likelihood of writing a satisfactory book.
In terms of consideration,
it's plausible that West would not have been willing to make an unconditional
promise to pay the $4 extra,
uh,
per page.
This abstinence condition might have been what induced,
uh,
west to promise to pay more money.
And so the condition seems to satisfy the bargain for or inducement conception
of consideration.
On the other hand,
the law of conditions fosters a policy favoring freedom from contract.
If an express condition proceeding has failed the promise or may be discharged
from the contract without any obligation to compensate the promise.
He for past performance,
whether a promise or like west was in fact prejudiced by the failure to remain
abstinent is in material.
On the other hand,
the strict application of the law of conditions can produce forfeitures,
especially where the promissory has not actually prejudice by the failure of a
condition and the promise he has engaged in extensive preparation to perform or
indeed has uh,
uh,
performed in the past put differently if the condition turns out to be in
material to the promise or and discharge will cause promising to forfeit her
reliance,
uh,
in any country and has conferred a benefit on the promise or discharging the
promise or may provide a severe test for uh,
our commitment to freedom from a contract policy courts.
So dislike the forfeitures that enforcement of conditions can have,
that they are both willing to allow waiver,
uh,
waivers or modifications without consideration and they are willing as a factual
matter to find waiver where there are serious questions as to whether waiver
actually took place.
A waiver has been defined generally as the voluntary relinquishment of unknown
right in the context of express conditions of promissor may voluntarily
relinquished the right to insist on an express condition.
Analysis reveals waivers of express conditions are associated with three
recurring fact patterns,
election waiver,
Estoppel waiver,
and the waiver without either election or Estoppel.
These three fact patterns are aptly illustrated by insurance contract examples.
First,
let's think about election waiver.
Imagine that plaintiff insured has not satisfied and express condition that
notice be given within 30 days after a covered accident,
but defended insurer with full knowledge Aleks to process the claim rather than
deny payment.
Because of the promises election to process the claim after the condition has
failed,
the insurer cannot thereafter insist upon the condition.
Waiver is here inferred from the promise of wars conduct estoppel waiver.
Instead,
it can be seen in the following example immediately after the accident.
Imagine that defendant insurer tells plaintiff insured not to worry about the 30
day notice condition.
Relying on this,
the plaintiff submits notice within 45 days of the accident and then the
defendant refuses to process the claim.
The condition is waived because plaintiff has materially changed his or her
position in reliance upon defendant's representation.
Waiver is inferred from the promissory his words,
the representation and the promises.
Reliance waiver without election or Estoppel can be seen in this example after
the plaintiff insured has substantially performed the contract.
Defendant states that it will not insist upon a nonmaterial condition.
The condition is waived without election or Estoppel,
but more broadly when one party has promised are represented that he or she will
not insist upon express conditions.
Waiver becomes a judicial device to avoid forfeiture.
In particular cases where an agreed modification cannot be found.
The willingness of courts defined waiver without reliance or Estoppel is another
indication of the judicial hostility to conditions and their potential for
forfeiture.
It shouldn't surprise you that many courts will not enforce anti waiver
provisions,
which for example might say that waivers must be supported by consideration or
that waivers of conditions must be in writing.
Finding the courts find that such anti waiver provisions are also waived by the
party's conduct or words
in Clark versus West.
The plaintiff's claim that the copyright of the book in the name of a
corporation of West Corporation violated the terms of the agreement.
This possible bad action and copywriting.
The book in the name of the corporation might have been the real dispute in the
case west by incorporating was playing fast and loose with the copyright to
Clark's book and might this had been made it easier for the court to find a
waiver on the abstinence condition?
Well,
this is a legal realist question influenced by the forfeiture issue.
Clark completed the book without apparently any quality impairment and the
profits were we're rolling in.
This implies that West got what it really bargained for and could gain a
windfall through this forfeiture.
So if west is playing games with the copyright and is trying to get a book worth
$6 a page for $2 but the court a good court supposed to do.
Let's review.
Today,
we talked about waivers of express conditions.
We learned that the promise or benefiting from an express condition may waive
that condition without the promise.
See,
providing any consideration for the modification if the condition does not go to
core consideration of the original contract.